Whether my brother just has
this expression where you
just kind of gives me the
slow nod,
which is he's gone,
you know,
my father was dead and I went in and I
saw him on a Gurney and shit and it was
so strange and I go
outside and I was a smoker,
like cigarette smoker in those days I
was going to have a cigarette and uh,
Donald comes out and I was like,
uh,
oh,
this is a shock and whatever,
you know,
we're upset and stuff.
And uh,
I said,
how was it because he was there.
what happened?
And Donald tells me the story of like
a dad woke up and had this like big
reaction.
Like just like,
I'm hot,
there's thrown the sheets off.
And Mom Freq test.
She's like,
what's the matter?
What's the matter?
She told Donald Call,
I'd call the ambulance,
call the hospital,
and he was gone within seconds.
So that's bad enough.
You know,
he was hot and uncomfortable.
You don't want to hear like,
oh,
he died in his sleep and we
woke up and he just didn't.
But then my brother says,
this thing probably defined my life.
My brother goes,
uh,
he died screaming and I go,
what?
And he goes,
he,
he died screaming.
And I was like,
w I mean as,
is that a figure of speech?
And he goes,
no,
he literally,
he died screaming and you could
see my brother was haunted by it.
And my father wasn't like a,
I wouldn't say he was a
butch man or a strong man,
but he wasn't a soft men money
stretch of the imagination.
And I never heard him get real
loud or anything like that.
And the notion of my father dying,
screaming,
changed my life.
Cause I was like,
even a good man in this world.
You played a game,
he played straight.
You play by the rules,
you do everything you're supposed to,
you're going to die screaming.
And at that point I was like,
there's no point in not trying to
accomplish every stupid fucking dream I've
got.
Even if it's dumb shit,
like fucking,
you know,
Oh my God,
I've always wanted to collect this money.
Fucking a Wayne Gretzky
cards in one fucking binder.
Or if it's like I want to make a movie,
or if it's like I want to put on a podcast
or I want to do a TV show now I want
to write a book,
chase it all down.
Chasing whimsy is what I've been
doing for the last few years.
Just smoking weed and chances went
whimsies anytime I'm like back in the day,
I'd have a good idea,
something I really wanted
to follow through on it.
And also you can get scared.
You start thinking about some of what
some of the fucker's going to say and be
like,
oh,
it's stupid.
Why would you fucking do that?
And fucking why?
Why?
A lot of why people in this world,
I try to surround myself with the why
nots motherfuckers who you're like,
I want to try this.
Like why not?
Let's go,
let's give it a shot.
You gotta be game man.
People help you achieve
your dreams and shit.
So for me,
the last few years I've just been trying
to accomplish every dopey dream to big
shit.
The little shit you got to do them all.
You can't just do the
climb every mountain shit,
you know he did sometimes late a bar down,
step over it and be like to the house so
you feel accomplished but chase it all
and do it all because we're all gonna
die screaming and you might as well enjoy
it here and I and when I say chase Saul,
don't fucking do it at the
expense of someone else.
Obviously don't hurt somebody
else but go after your dreams man.
If your dream is to like I
want to kill 12 children,
that's,
I'm not saying I'm not talking to you,
but go after your dreams if
they're not going to hurt anybody.
You seem now I wish I knew you before you
became famous because you seem like if
I had a guess,
I bet you haven't changed at all.
Pretty much know how
did you navigate that?
That's a very friends,
those dudes like those days
that I was like kitten,
the bell,
like they don't want it do the
show and that is that they,
they really don't want it.
I mean,
not really like Kevin,
we don't want to do this,
but Walter is just like,
Oh man,
they just grounded you so much.
You never gave into the
tide of those two craziness.
I've got friends.
I mean,
I've never had butch friends who like
fucking punch you and wrestle lunch called
butch.
I mean it is to a fake dude like me.
That's Bush,
Dude.
Those are bullies.
But like the hard Boyz is,
my mom used to say it was good.
We'll leave those hardy boys alone.
Kevin,
I never had,
I didn't have the rough house playing
around like let's wrestle and shit like
that.
What I had was more psychological,
more oral,
and that sounds dirty,
but I don't mean oral.
More like the dozens.
Motherfuckers keeping it tight.
You grow up fat,
you gotta be fucking sharp.
Stand your toes or else you're a fucking
victim every time you walk in the room,
because most of the world
don't look like you.
So you get sharp.
You learn how to fucking take yourself
out first before anybody else can steal
their thunder.
Hey,
I'm fucking fat.
And then people are like,
oh,
you know,
and then there you've
removed their fucking card.
He'd taken their biggest weapon out of
their quiver to biggest thing they got
and then suddenly you've
changed the focus and hey,
he's easy with himself,
blah,
blah.
And it makes people allegiant,
you know,
just all that shit you
pick up over the years,
you see it.
It's,
it's what shapes you.
It's what makes you who you are.
So being able to hang out with people
who were quick enough to like shred you,
but you had to be able to
protect yourself and funny.
And it's like hanging out with Ninjas
all the time who just or not in India so
much as Keto from the old pink panther
movies were just hired them to literally
attack him out of nowhere.
That's what your friends do.
They just like attack you
out of fucking nowhere.
And so by doing this all the time,
it made me sharp,
but it also kept me very,
very real.
So these cats,
even when the movies would take off,
where were I was doing
this one or this one,
they were never like,
oh my God,
the fucking,
we had no idea you were hidden genius.
They remain the same exact individuals.
So I didn't like that one.
Oh fuck yes.
Really?
Yes.
Oh yes.
In a heartbeat.
They'll let you know and they'll let you,
like I brought them on a mall,
rats to come work on the movie
and stuff and they made it,
they were in it in a few scenes
but they worked behind the scenes.
They quit after about two
weeks cause they're just like,
I don't want to do this.
I have no interest in this.
I mean,
and that's cool.
Like I respected that.
I was like [inaudible] that's Brian.
That's Walter.
Like that's who they are.
Rather than be like,
all right man,
we're going to do it because
it might upset Kev if we don't.
They're just like,
oh we don't want to do this dude.
What makes the Dyno self kind of thing?
I'm sorry,
what makes you think that without
them you wouldn't be you though?
What makes you think that without them
you wouldn't have pulled yourself to the
ground?
I wouldn't have had that sense of humor.
I think my sense of humor
largely came from them,
largely came from my friend Brian Johnson
and Walter also kind of shaped it to
some degree.
I was,
I've,
I was funny,
like don't get me wrong.
And,
and high in high school I write sketches
for the comedy shows and Shit like
that.
But I there it was their sensibility
married to whatever sensibility I had is
one of three kids,
raised Catholic and highlands New Jersey.
That clicked that like kind
of made me the version of me,
you know,
the person that you would want to meet
or the person like that was different was
like Kev 18 years old,
1718,
before we started hanging
out with Brian and Walter.
Um,
those were the cats that kind
of helped me define who I was.
And if you look at clerks like that
movie is [inaudible] Dante and my friend
Brian Johnson has meant to be Randall.
The guy that I most wanted to be like,
he knew,
always knew what to say was fucking
funny in a room and shit like that.
Really misanthropic and stuff.
And so that it kind of all communicated
without those cats that I don't think I
know I wouldn't have the jobs I've had
cause I wouldn't have the sense of humor
I have now.
And I don't think I'd be if,
let's say I got into
entertainment somehow,
I doubt I'd be as grounded.
Knowing those dudes have kept
me kind of grounded for years.
That's pretty cool man.
It's good.
It's good to have something
like that and your life,
man.
Well,
I have any similar can weed,
why aren't you smoking weed?
I thought this is a weed show.
We already got high and
let's get higher
experiencing it.
Hire Kevin just gave me a heart
attack and he did his even realize it.
What way?
By talking about all that life thing.
I almost died a Friday night when I,
uh,
was out.
And you just told me,
and I'm like,
uh,
I was at a karaoke bar in Burbank
right across the street from a,
the Jay Leno show,
like the NBC building temples.
I've see,
I've,
see,
I drive past that.
I've seen that place.
I came out,
me and my girlfriend around 1130 when
we walking out the front and we parked.
So I'm opening the door for her to get in.
I have no where this big,
tall black guy,
about six to wearing a fake gray beard,
like a Santa Claus beard that was like
tied on with white strings and a hat in
this big Hobo jacket shows a
gun in my chest and was like,
give me your fucking wallet.
Oh man,
you're harsher.
My boss.
Yeah,
nevermind.
Keep going.
And then my girlfriend was,
my girlfriend was pretty drunk.
That's good.
Here's,
my girlfriend was pretty drunk,
so because she has like social anxiety,
so she drinks,
you know,
when she goes out,
she thought it was a joke.
She looked over and thought this
was like a character or something.
Right.
And so he's like,
give a shit,
you're shaking telling him,
you can tell it's still fun.
Yeah.
Fucking night,
I would fuck me up,
keep going.
And so he said,
uh,
he said,
um,
you know,
give me your fucking purse bitch.
And she just like,
like looking at him,
like what?
Like she was drunk and
shocked and I'm like,
give her,
give him the person.
So I get gave her or she gave
him the purse and then he goes,
get in the car,
lay on your fucking stomach.
And he's shoving the gun in my
back while I'm laying in the car.
And I'm thinking like,
all right,
this is like execution style.
Like he's telling me to,
you know,
get in there and then suddenly he goes,
get laid down to the,
to my girlfriend.
And she laid down on her back
because she was just so freaked out.
He said,
I said later on your
fucking stomach bitch.
And he's like,
she's shoving a gun in her back.
And then finally we just like both laying
there and then he slams the door and
just takes off.
And so now,
like the other day I was at the grocery
store and I saw a black guy that was
tall and I'm now I'm
like freaking out like,
and if it was a red head that robbed
me would have been the same way.
But now I see these guys and I'm like
becoming like a racist from the 50s now
where I'm like walking around,
I'm like,
what's he doing on my side of the store?
You know,
like it's crazy.
It's like at this point you had your,
you were in that moment.
Yeah.
What did you,
what was it like?
It was really when I was
laying there and it was like,
this is it.
And but you think that they think,
what did you think?
You know,
I didn't think about anything
except my girlfriend the whole time.
And I'm like,
cause hearing him yell at her,
that's just you.
You think that you can just kind of
look around and look for a weapon or
something like that.
But when you're in that biggest shock,
you're just like,
oh,
I wouldn't look to fence lines.
So not the butch dude.
That's again,
there's a word I'm showing up.
The dude that's like,
where's a weapon?
I'm going to do this.
My immediate,
my reaction is going to be like,
let me suck your Dick.
Let us go.
I will suck your Dick until
you let us go and he's like,
you've got a girlfriend.
I'm like,
still,
I'll be better than her.
Yeah,
I can really deliver.
I,
that's where I go with,
I would never go defensive or offensive.
All these people in line,
of course it's like,
Doug,
what'd you get for not doing Jujitsu?
Like if I had two guns in my pocket,
I still was doing it,
but fuck yeah.
I mean if you add yourself
strapped the dynamite,
maybe then you could be a little,
look at this bitch,
right people,
those you should have.
People should shut the fuck up.
No one knows what that's like until that
happens to you and you should always
give someone what they want.
Usually they just want to fucking
get your money and run away.
They don't want to shoot you.
Is that the case?
Usually you hear at
once in a while though,
like,
like Old Lady,
you know,
did nothing still gets shot
or something like that.
If it's a young kid on fucking PCP,
it's really a gamble.
This is a birthday and then time where
you believing about midnight and three
months before that or six months before
that I was in Fuddrucker's in Burbank
and some guys like stealing this girl's
person running out the door and I'm
chasing him.
I'm like,
I'm in Burbank right now.
Why?
You know,
and we talked about,
uh,
the Kmart shooting in one podcast,
the,
there was a shooting at Kmart in Burbank
and the officer that got shot was the
one that came to rescue
me when the other night.
And I was like,
you're the,
you're the one officer.
And he's like,
yeah,
he got,
he got shot in the leg
and stuff like that.
And so he became like a
celebrity guy because,
well he's been shot at in Burbank and,
and Kmarts like,
you know,
makes saw him on TV.
But it's like,
it's like,
it seems like you always hear Burbank
is so safe and stuff you don't think at
Burbank is like Bob and lived there.
How could it be right
there could be no terror.
Well,
liquid lake.
I wonder how many checks one of bone,
that guy because he,
the celebrity cop that got shot.
Well I had to wait a bunch.
Right.
Gotta be right.
There are checks that
doesn't fuck fat dude.
You gotta be checks that
wanna fuck fucking a hero cop.
He wrote cop that got shot in the leg.
I bet that guy gets beaten off the
pussy just waiting for forensics.
Like I had to wait like four hours
because I mean this is like the closed off
helicopters and everything.
That was like cops and stuff and
then they wanted a fingerprint,
my car.
So I'm just sitting there and he's
like going ask him my girlfriend like
questions like weird questions like,
so what do you do?
Oh,
you're dance.
Uh Huh.
Yeah.
Well you look like you ain't and
stuff like it was a computer.
No,
he was totally an awesome,
nice cop.
But it was kind of weird like hearing
like my girlfriend having to talk like,
yeah,
it was an exotic dancer.
No,
but just asking weird questions.
And then was he going as close to hitting
on her as he could and still remaining
a cop?
Was he doing like with this guy?
Yeah,
he was,
I don't know.
You see me and they see my girlfriend.
Maybe he thought I was like paid for her,
like if she was a hooker or something,
you know,
like how long do you know this guy you
gotta like he said exactly in Brian Flux,
we'll reserve.
But,
but what's weird is,
I don't even know what it was weird.
Oh,
but we're just,
when he was talking to me and asked
me all these questions and he goes,
well,
and I was like,
yeah,
I would like to be a cop,
but I like marijuana too much.
And he goes,
yeah,
I see that.
Yeah,
you know,
marijuana.
And he's like,
it's going to be legal soon,
so don't worry about that.
And I was like,
all right,
this cough is Korea.
I don't know if he's got
a fucking crystal ball.
Yeah,
come on man.
Come on.
And that was the only silver lining to
that horrible story was like at the end
of it,
the cop was like,
don't worry kid.
One day we,
it's going to be lean now
I'm scared of black wizards.
Wizards.
I'm going to be,
Halloween are going to
be one black wizard.
It's going to tack it onto the
Spring Mass at any be an internet.
Me and my friend,
black wizard wizard.
You're scared of monsters.
You know like where I
was smoking my strike.
Let's get a werewolves,
bro.
I love you were a little stir.
Now I'm scared of Jaguars and pants.
Did you find the monsters or the video?
I tweeted the other day of a
Jaguar killing a fucking crocodile.
Somebody tweeted it to
me and I retweeted it.
It's a Jaguar killing a fucking crocodile.
How scary are Jaguars?
I don't think there's a crocodile in
the reference you've made to a Jaguar.
You they do care.
Care led Zepplin and big cats.
The cats to me.
Yeah.
Well,
not here,
unfortunately,
but there are pumas in this neighborhood.
Really?
Oh yeah.
For Real.
Yeah.
Whenever we see deer,
this deer in this neighborhood
and there's pumas.
All right,
so there's two.
It's not stay out of this one at Burbank.
It's not uncommon that people have spotted
them in this community several times.
Really?
Like mountain cats.
I mean there's there,
there's a known population of them that
live like around Topanga Canyon in this
area and they travel really far.
Like one of them,
they tracked from South Dakota
all the way to Connecticut.
They get hit,
he got hit by a car and Connecticut.
And they had decided,
I saw this.
Yeah,
they did the DNA test on this fucker
and they found out that it's from South
Dakota.
So this is from a group of
genetics from South Dakota.
This thing had walked 1800 miles.
He was looking for sugar
to put in this to a lump.
Ooh.
Three or,
or a dog or two eating some
nice plump dogs along the way.
They do downing months.
All right man.
Let's change up the topic
cause you're scaring me now.
Now I don't want to go out to my car and
this neighborhood and I don't want to
watch the video of the Jaguar killing
a crocodile cause it's fucking amazing
because you think you look at a crocodile
and you look at that as a God damn
dinosaur designers,
farmer,
evil lizard.
Like what?
Who would fuck with that?
And the Jaguar,
it's just like playful
with this fucking crock.
And I like knows it's going to kill it.
Just playing with it.
Swats added pause at it.
Just looks for the right moment,
get sideways on it and then
right behind the fucking head.
It's crazy.
It's like what?
Uh,
if,
if they're not scared of Croghan miles
now do we have the US fleshy bags of
pink,
you know,
these big black,
muscular,
evil looking cats
in a world where you been following
up on a wildlife tech stores.
You've been seeing all the bear stories
like the two bears in Yellowstone this
year,
the Animal Beers,
two guys who've been killed by
bears in Yellowstone this year.
It's rare you read that story online
about the kid who got bit by a polar bear.
Yeah.
That was fucking astounding.
The dude literally tells a story
where him and his trooper on,
you know,
they're out in the fucking
woods or something like that.
And there's a kid sleeping next to him,
a sleep in a tent.
And this polar bear comes
fucking through the tent.
The kid woke up to like wailing and
gnashing of teeth and the fucking thing,
ground and blood all over its face
and the thing bid him on the head,
had his head in its mouth of polar
bear had his kids had in his mouth.
And he said,
it bits so hard,
they cracked his fucking skull
and he heard it crack in his head.
And what he also heard in his head,
louder than life,
sense around style from
the 70s was growlin because
it's fucking mouth was over
his ears.
And he starts punching this
fucking beast in the head,
punching it,
and they had real hard and shit.
And finally let's go enough for him to
like make a move or something like that.
So He's,
he survived the body.
His body was right next to him died
and they interviewed the kid and he's
talking about,
he's like,
I got a lot of guilt man.
Like it could have been me if I'd
slept on that side I'd be dead.
But I'm like,
dude,
you got your head bit by a polar bear.
That's,
I'm not going to say it's worse,
but that's pretty damn.
So he got away and it just
went after his friend next.
No,
his friend was done for,
by the time the kid woke up,
the polar bear had taken what it wanted,
I think from the,
his friend did Malta
instantly it says face.
Oh my God.
Yeah man.
Nature.
What do you think it is?
You think it's like they're hungry and
a weather condition changes and they're
just coming into the neighborhoods now.
Cause you don't hear a lot
about this back in the day,
but a lot of it happening now.
A lot of more shark attacks,
lot more bear attacks.
Maybe the really true statistically,
well I'm asking,
I know know more.
Maybe it's just,
I'm reading more about it.
Well,
where we have more access to information.
I do know that they said with this yellow
stone attack to the last time there
had been a death from
bears and Yellowstones.
It was an [inaudible] 86 yeah.
Yeah.
So that's a long time man.
I mean,
Shit,
you know,
that's a long ass time for nothing,
nothing to get killed.
And then all of a sudden two
people get killed quickly.
But those two people could have been
sprinkled any time along the way.
It's,
you're in the wrong place.
The wrong time.
You Zig when you should have zagged.
It didn't rain enough.
So the fucking is not enough food and
then all sudden bear start eating other
things.
Bears are omnivores.
That's the crazy thing about them.
They can eat whatever the fuck they want.
So it's like us.
But the terrible thing about bears is
because they're not strict carnivores.
They don't kill their
prey before they eat it.
They just start eating as I'm going to
stand for a bit and I just don't want the
camera looking at my Dick.
The whole,
we could all stand.
No,
I just want to stress.
no,
I'm all good.
How long do I stand for the cop
not wait till it gets awkward
and then I'll kick back down.
Dear balls ever fall asleep from sitting
too much like I've lately I think I've
been sitting a certain way
where it squeezes the blood
blood pressure off on one
of my balls and then it feels
like my whole crutches a numb.
That's the inevitable progression to you.
Growing a vagina.
It was going to happen.
What happened?
Balls are gonna,
they're gonna melt
together and then pop open.
Like you remember that scene and John
Carpenter's the thing where the chest
cavity opens up and becomes a big mouth.
Yeah.
That's going to be your
new book comes off.
That's your new pussy.
No,
my balls.
I'll fall asleep.
Usually.
Never have you never had that happen.
It's such a weird feeling.
No,
but my good.
Should I try it?
No,
it's horrible.
I do the Ari Shaffir sometimes
though when I'm reading a,
you know,
he has a joke about,
uh,
taking a shit and his leg go numb and
you'd get off and fall down to the ground.
I read magazines all
the time and the toilet,
and you do,
if you read magazines,
you're essentially,
you're choking out your leg.
That's why Jiu Jitsu works.
Jiu Jitsu works cause he cut off the
blood and what you're doing when your feet
go numb is you're putting all this
pressure on yourself and wait,
you're,
you're essentially choking out your legs.
You're making hemorrhoids.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
And when,
when you choke someone
out in a Jujitsu choke,
what you're doing is you're
stopping the blood to their brain.
You're cutting it off,
stopping it from
happening at squeezing it.
And that's what you're doing when
you're sitting here on the toilet.
If you have this hard surface beneath
your leg and then you're on top of your
leg,
you're basically giving
your feet a slow choke.
Oh my God,
Dude.
All right.
I do this all the time.
I do too.
I sit on the toilet for so long.
When I get up,
I got pins and needles and I can't walk
the hall and then like sometimes I'll
try to man up and get through it,
but by the time I hit the bedroom like
you start laughing because it's so you're
out of control because the nerve is
are all dead and my wife's just like,
how long when you get to learn,
like you go in your shit,
you get out.
Like why aren't you staying in there
till your fucking leg falls asleep?
And I was like,
cause I'm getting shit done.
But I,
it's,
I guess that's unhealthy.
I read car magazines.
Is that what you do?
I go on the Internet.
It's the only time I read car magazines.
I don't,
I won't let myself go in
the Internet in the toilet.
That's where it gets ridiculous.
I'm like,
I'm down to the occasional
magazine at least.
Let me finish up.
Matt Taibbi Rolling Stone article in
here on the crapper do wipe sitting up or
sitting down.
What the fuck you mean stand who you,
I've never done that.
You never stand in wiped up?
Only
when I was a kid.
And this is weird.
Wow.
All right.
You're getting something out of me.
I've haven't said publicly.
It may be ever when I was a kid,
I remember,
uh,
like I take a shit,
I'm trying to remember
what age the stopped,
but I'd be like,
I'm done.
And somebody would get up,
he'd stand up and they'd
wipe your ass for you.
And I think I did that
till I was like seven,
which is weird.
It is weird.
Yeah.
But it was pretty good.
Like in terms of like,
I didn't really have to figure out how
to fucking wipe my own shit for until
that point.
And then you had to train yourself
to do it from sitting down.
I think it's an ever perfected and ever
perfecting art form the art of the wipe.
It's not,
you know,
there's no one true measure and,
and I think it develops as you get older,
you learn better technique and stuff.
But um,
no,
not since then.
I've never stent,
I'm a more of a front wiper though.
Like I'll reach,
cause I got a lot of back fat.
Rather than reach around,
I'll reach through my lean
forward and reach through my legs.
So I'm wiping almost like my man puss,
but I clear the ball so it doesn't
hit my balls or anything like that.
Fascinating.
You walked away.
The wet wipes have really helped my life.
They just come out of nowhere.
It couldn't.
They have those in the 70 [inaudible]
will Smith was the first one
that called them to my potential.
I mean they had baby wipes forever,
but these flushables asshole
cleaning of fishing out.
Yeah.
Big Time Man.
He talks about it and he did.
He literally talks about an interview.
He was just like Barry Barry Sonnenfeld
on men and black turned me on to wet
wipes for handy wipes for,
for going.
And he's like,
why would you use toilet
paper when you can use this?
And he's like,
I haven't gone back since.
And so one day I went out and got a pack.
I was like,
this is fucking amazing.
It's like taking a,
she flushed them,
but these are flushable so you can
at least say they're pleasurable.
Let me tell you what happens.
I,
I've used it for years and never had it
problem.
You were probably about to,
I had a set
problem with what not.
I had a,
I had a tree growing inside my,
my pipe here.
Oh Dude.
It was the most ridiculous thing.
I tweeted it.
It's almost impossible
to find now someone,
someone on the Internet,
I'll find it,
but it's a,
uh,
literally there was a branch
growing like it was huge.
It's crazy root system and everything
that was growing in my toilet,
I kept having this clogged up toilet.
Didn't matter if I port draino
on it and nothing would work.
So I had these guys come over.
I figured they just going
to snake the toilet.
Will they cut out a fucking tree because
nature is such a motherfucker that a
tiny crack had grown in one of the pipes
and these a route from one of the low,
the nearby trees had forced its way
into this and found out that there's all
this water in this area.
So spread apart the pipe by
growing and then grew up the pipe.
It's incredible.
It was just an invasion by this plant
species living off my poop and it was all
clogged up with those little
fucking flushable wipes,
those flushable wipes.
You know how the flushable wipe comes
in like that little treasure chest,
you can just get like refill
it and throw it in there.
I don't do that for that long because
if you look at like the taint or the
button of
the thing,
you know sometimes if you had a second
wife you might have a little poo on your
hand and that builds up.
If you smell that it
smells like an asshole.
I never used the button bring,
I just open it and draw them
out for that very reason.
I don't want to touch cool button ever.
Yeah.
What's up with that,
right?
Yeah.
Poobah that's a silly move.
Did they give you a rubber
glove to use that thing was,
that's what they should follow
because you give you a rubber glove.
That should be what?
The wipe to the deep sincere.
I'll take them.
I'll go knuckle deep to why when
you're cleaning yourself out.
Exactly.
You never know.
If somebody gonna be like,
tonight's the night I might eat your ass.
So people are so funny about assholes.
No real.
Are these people uncomfortable about it?
Don't like you talking about your own.
Just like certain things
you can talk about.
You can talk all day about your y'all.
I have psoriasis on my elbow.
It's really annoying.
It's itchy and scratchy.
Look at my Eczema.
But you started talking about,
man,
I just,
you guys ever like just
massaging your asshole.
Do you massage your ass off?
Then people are like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
You know,
you could say,
dude,
when I get home I'd massage
my neck on the way home.
You know,
sometimes it gets so stiff.
I just give it a solid massage on my own.
I feel so much better.
Yeah.
Yeah,
me too.
I know what you mean.
I like to massage my asshole.
It feels really good.
It feels,
no,
I don't,
but,
but if someone said that,
you know,
but do you know?
No,
that'd be awesome.
But it's something about you talking
about your asshole and pleasure that makes
me terrified.
Does it really?
Okay.
I'll tell you a pain story about salaries
because it's sitting on the toilet,
as you said,
for all that time.
I got an anal fissure.
Oh,
Jesus.
You ever had one of those?
No.
You never want one of these.
This,
I've never,
I've never been punched in the
face or choked out or anything.
Fucking cool,
but this was the most pain I think
I've ever felt in my entire life.
Really.
It's that ring it,
that sphincter is the fulcrum.
Your entire body.
You start to discover anything you
do reverberates in your asshole.
I know it sounds deep.
It's not move your finger.
You can feel it when arm.
You can feel it and you
only really realize it when
there's something wrong down
there.
And an anal fissure is when there's
a tear right on the fucking lip.
Uracil somewhere on the ring or this
one extended it a little deeper and I,
I didn't know what it was.
It's painful,
man.
Like so painful that like I asked my
wife and my wife's never fucking see me
completely naked,
let alone my asshole.
I literally was like,
I'm going to ask you to
do that fucking thing.
I never imagined I'd ask
another human being to do.
And she's like,
what?
And I was like,
I'm going to lay on the bed.
I'm a fucking crane.
Open my two fucking cheeks.
I'm gonna need you to look in there
and tell me if something looks funky.
Now
I've never even seen my own asshole,
but I know for a fact,
dude,
I've got hair down there too,
so I'm,
I'm,
I'm telling her,
I'm like,
now you might have to deal with
a little shrubbery down there.
There's no manscaping.
So if that's the case,
you might have to move hair.
And she's like,
oh my God,
please don't make me do this.
Like there's
no one but you.
I was like,
I'm sorry.
I wouldn't have,
I was in pain,
dude.
It was,
and I was crying.
It's hurts so much.
So I lay down,
she's looking at it and she was like,
I don't know.
There's just so many roles,
you know,
she couldn't get to it.
I was like,
come on,
do you see any blood?
She's like,
I think I see some blood.
I think I see like an inflamed area.
And I went to a doctor and the doctor,
it's like,
get up on the table and whatnot,
and I'd never want to Approch tologist
and I'm laying on the table and he opens
my cheek and he doesn't even,
he puts a flashlight on the
outside of my fucking ring piece.
He done,
I'm waiting for her to
like the fletch move.
We're moving along river.
He takes a look with just the flashlight.
He goes,
oh,
anal fissure.
I go,
really?
Is that what it is?
He goes,
yeah.
I was like,
you're going to,
you don't want to go deeper.
He's going,
I don't need to.
And he's going,
you don't want me to either.
And I said,
what do you do about them?
It's going to give you two,
uh,
creams.
One's topical,
one a little more insertion.
He's going,
uh,
basically,
what was the figure?
He said,
God,
I can't remember.
He said,
in eight to 10 weeks,
you'll start feeling 50% better.
And I looked at him like,
dude,
what are you kidding me?
And it may not have been eight 10 may
have been four or five but it was a long
period of time,
only 50% better.
And I was like two that
I don't like these odds.
He's like,
that's as best I could do.
that's either that he can go for surgery,
but trust me,
you don't want that.
He's like,
I said,
what surgeries?
Like,
well basically we get in there
and the needle and sew you up.
I'm like,
forget it.
I'll wait for it to heal.
And it was fucking misery getting
in with a needle and sew you up.
And then how long does
it take for that thing?
And then it takes her a
while to fucking heels.
So their whole thing is like,
just keep prompting this
topical on it and natural.
It'll heal itself.
Try not to fucking rough around with them.
Like I don't want to even go near it.
Going around with your bundle.
Yeah,
I'm like to use those terms,
I said,
doc,
I went around with it son.
I said like Joe Rogan,
I like to massage my asshole.
What will this mean for that?
But he said,
uh,
he was like,
it's very common.
He goes,
if you're in a room,
45% of the people in the room are
dealing with anal fissure and he's gone.
Nobody talks about it.
I said,
why?
He's gone because it has everything
to do with your ass hole.
He's calling people.
He was saying the exact same thing.
He's like,
people don't talk about
this kind of thing.
Public,
it'd be much easier because you wouldn't
have people waiting as long as they do
to come in.
It's going,
it's common practice.
He says,
you know how yours happened?
And I was like,
I don't know.
I thought he was going to be like
a lot of fucking bathroom activity,
man.
A lot of fucking blow
glory holes and Shit.
I said,
no,
I don't know how it happened.
And he said,
you sit on the toilet a lot.
I bet.
I said,
I do.
As a matter of fact,
he's going,
well,
your weight sitting on
that toilet and he's going,
I bet you don't just go and leave.
You sit there for awhile.
I said,
yeah,
he's gone.
It's just think about it.
Gravity's just pulling it that you know,
as you sit there,
it's not like you're sitting on the toilet
and your butt cheeks are clenched in
your asshole is fucking tight.
Is that how you do?
I'll tell him nothing's getting in here.
Excellent posture.
Your shit comes out through your balls.
My Shit comes out when I tell it to
all look out.
Do you never want
that?
Oh my God,
that sounds horrible.
So I remember,
so only 50% fist six weeks,
50% when we're done.
Did it take until it was 100% oh,
honestly it felt like months.
I think it was months for months.
All I could do literally
was like lay on the bed,
belly down.
And if I took it on,
oddly enough,
when I took a shit,
it felt better,
but it only felt better for the moment
on I was taking the shit because then I
guess what?
I don't know what I don't know.
I can't even tell you the science of it,
but when I took a shit,
I felt better.
As soon as I was done taking a shit.
That's when the agony kicked in of like
reminding you it was there and you would
literally just flinch
and squirm on the bed,
like fucking withdrawn
or something like that.
It was men nasty.
Yeah.
The last thing you want
to get household problem.
Yeah.
It's the fulcrum of your body.
I had to internal hemorrhoid for that
reason and they had to do the rubber band
technique where they Tyrol band around
inside your asshole and he tight super
tight so it gets no blood
supply and it falls off.
Well,
I'm like this is this going to hurt?
And he goes,
no,
it's more of an annoying pain.
And I'm like,
all right.
I go home and it was like somebody shoving
their like fingernail into your ass
hole from the inside and just sing there
and twisting it and turning it like a
fucking shit passage.
It's shit.
Get caught up on the banner.
No,
I don't know.
How big is this thing that you can
wrap a rubber band around it and it was
pretty big.
And then her having get rid of the
hemorrhoid or grape or whatever.
I've had a hemorrhoid before they said
that I was supposed to go back maybe two
or three times.
This is a whole process.
The first time it's
probably not going to do it.
I wouldn't go back to the second one.
So now I live with the little guy and
he's just this little teeny guy now.
But once in a while if he eats like if
I eat the wrong thing it blows up and is
like Yo bitch,
not Jews claim to clamp style.
You still have it in there tied up?
No,
no,
no.
The rubber band dissolved but it's
the internal hemorrhoids still exists.
Yeah,
he's got a clip so I just
returns whenever it wants to.
It went whenever I like get crazy,
eat a bunch of hot peppers or for eating.
It's hot peppers.
It's a lot of fucking like caffeine.
It's a lot of like really?
I had heard that it's from
greasy forcing your shit out.
Monitors from pushing like I've got a
resident just like yours is mostly quiet.
Nice.
Lodger but periodically,
hey,
if I'm down here and it's always fun,
I'm fucking up like on the
toilet and I'm fucking pushing.
Maybe I'm not ready to go,
but I'm like,
if I don't go now,
I'm not going to be able to
go for a couple of hours.
Once in awhile he shoots somebody
and there's blood everywhere.
You know it's like a code.
Yes.
Oh yes.
My buddy.
Yeah.
Bloody nose.
No big deal.
Bloody asshole.
Oh,
for reals.
Want to go to the fights,
dude.
Some of them were last time around.
I'm going to fight.
We got to do it.
Roll a camera on me though.
Okay.
So are you could watch me for sure.
Well,
there's,
um,
there's going to be a big card
on Fox coming up real soon.
Um,
uh,
I think it's November.
That I don't want to say,
I think it's the 14th.
I have to look at his schedule,
but it's,
uh,
it's going to be on Fox and I think
they're announcing tomorrow who the,
uh,
the fighters are,
but
that'll be an Anaheim.
So that's fucking clothes.
And you do all of them.
Are you always the guy?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
All right.
I didn't do this.
I don't have to buy tickets for this shit.
Yeah,
we'll hook you up,
man.
Come on Dawg.
Like you spend your money fucking Smith.
Kevin Smith
punched in that ring.
I want to make sure to get paid.
I'm happy.
Oh they get paid a motherfucker now.
They must be paid a
little bit of our gate.
Right.
That's how
it's different.
I mean they get different
deals but you know the gates,
it's almost always sold out.
Almost all the,
almost all of the domestic UFC sellout.
We've had a few problems
and other countries where
they really weren't like hip
on the UFC.
You know,
Germany wasn't like the biggest
success when we were over there.
We don't like this stop
hitting each other.
Didn't,
it wasn't like,
it's not like Australia.
Australia sells out in like an hour.
Whenever we put on a show in Australia,
people go fucking nuts,
but it was a little more difficult.
What about cooking it on its,
they blocked us from television
or something in Germany too.
There was something crazy or you
can only get it on paper view.
They couldn't have it on live television.
Germany,
Canada,
Canada is great because I always find
it's very similar to Australia or vice
versa.
Canada's awesome.
I fucking love Canada.
I would live there if
it wasn't so confusing,
you know,
if I didn't have to pay taxes
to two different countries,
GST and pst.
I think Vancouver's city's
government and the province,
you know you're paying,
it's the saint and essentially
federal and state taxes.
Yeah,
but then you also have
to pay for American too.
Unless you want to wait a minute.
If you want to live,
if you want to live in another country,
unless you want to give
up your citizen's suit,
you have to pay American taxes.
Yeah,
you would have to owe.
If you're talking about
doing dual citizen,
I'm not saying I hate America,
I just like,
I would,
I would live in Vancouver
and Vancouver is that shit.
[inaudible] fucking cities ever.
I'd go for Toronto Hockey Hall of fame.
I love Toronto,
but it gets cold as a motherfucker.
Don't whether I grew up in east coast,
I grew up in Boston and I'm scared.
You know,
it was,
you don't want to go back to Edmonton.
I would lack eyes too,
but my lady would never
let me live in Canada.
Man.
You guys don't like Vancouver.
Well,
my life,
Vancouver,
I,
she was at school there.
I shot a TV show there and movie.
They're like,
I do,
but it's not,
I'm not into whale art.
All right.
A lot of that up there,
man.
That and trees.
Fuck tree.
As a comic,
you know,
I,
I traveled too much,
man.
I would stand up and with the UFC I
traveled too much to risk being snowed in.
So if I live somewhere like Toronto,
I would always risk being stuck,
you know,
and you risk being stuck.
It's not,
it's not a sensible place to
live if you're a traveler,
unless of course,
you know,
you can,
figure out how to get out of town before
the snow hits and you work your other
and it shows up in the snowcat
snow cat up that mountain.
Totally,
man.
Just look out for the dude
behind the fucking ah,
with the ax.
I do think that I liked that one.
Did you didn't see that,
that Jack Nicholson motherfucker shining.
He couldn't shine that at all.
That was a great God damn movie.
Oh,
it's brilliant.
And Stephen King doesn't like it.
You know that.
Yeah.
No.
So
much so that he made sure
they made another one.
Assess makeup.
Make a worst one.
Make a terrible one.
This other one was too good.
Make a bad one.
Yeah,
that,
that other,
the TV movie one is tough.
I never saw the TV movie or remember it.
Even Weber from wings replaces Jack
Nicholson right then and there.
I mean my stealing
Steven Weber because he,
that's balls of steel dude.
You know what I'm saying?
To be like,
all right,
I'll give it a shot.
The dude or,
but to be fair is what heath
ledger did years later.
He stepped into a role at bat at that
Jack Nicholson made iconic and stuff.
That all being said,
hats off to Steven Weber
and movies a Tufts.
It,
yeah.
It ain't the shining by parents.
It was on so many pills.
He didn't even know what fucking,
you know what position he was
taken when Heath Ledger died,
he was on so many different pills.
Is that what they said?
Yeah.
Who knows?
Yeah,
he's his state of mind.
I mean,
when you hear it,
all the different shit that
he was on when he died,
that guy,
I mean there's,
there's a lot of those.
Don't give a fuck guys that can put in
like spectacular performances like that.
Like that heath ledger joker was a fucking
pretty spectacular performance when a
dude has something like
that and sign of him,
you know,
you don't,
that's a,
that's an a amazing abundance of energy
and you're not exactly sure how he's
controlling that.
Not everybody can have that kind of
a burst of energy inside of them and,
and,
and put it under control.
Some people like literally aren't
capable of that kind of a performance.
You think he was,
you think,
I think he's probably had a
little bit of crazy in a man.
No little bit of crazy.
And then he gets on pills.
Some cats just make pretend real well.
Yeah,
for sure.
No doubt about it.
But with all the pill thing and that I
don't want to place in his fucking like I
was high.
It's got into the headspace of the joker.
I don't even think that.
I don't know.
Not,
I just think he's just good,
but I'm just thinking that being really
brilliant at something like acting and
being completely fucking insane
or like next door neighbors,
man.
Yeah,
it's a thin line.
I agree with that total.
The ability to lock onto a character
so completely and captivating
and create it real.
Make it so real that
you're sitting there like,
look,
I love that joker performance.
It's spellbinding but I sit dial like
one movie back and look at them and the
gay cowboy picture that the
performance he gives him that movie,
that dude exists.
Like the joker performance is big
and it needs to be big and like pray.
You never meet someone
like that in your life,
but you would meet the carer.
I think it was ena Serenas he played
the character he played in Brokeback
mountain.
That performance is so
fucking frighteningly real.
That was the first time I was like
this mother fucker's or an actor.
I thought he was that dude from
10 things I hate about you.
But he had shops cause he made only
one other actor will to others parks.
Michael Parks did that for
me and from dusk till dawn,
like that's why I've read state exists.
Cause I watched the opening 10
minutes of from dusk till dawn back in
[inaudible] 95 I was like,
this mother fucker's Yoda.
Like how do I want to spend a month
on set with a dude who can drop site
performance
science,
this fucking brilliant,
this laser sharp,
this other worldly.
Um,
but then the other one,
God who was,
I just had it in my head.
What was the other one?
I said parks.
Oh,
Billy Bob Thornton in a simple plan.
Do you ever see a simple plan?
That fucking movie is a,
wasn't named guy.
Did Spiderman movie was us
as a movie with Bill Paxton.
Uh,
a simple plan.
Bill Paxton,
uh,
Bill Bill.
What's the,
what did I say his name was?
You know,
Billy,
what's his face?
I was going to that new guy,
guys fucked Angelina Jolie,
Billy Joe,
Billy,
Bob Thornton,
Jesus crap,
Billy Bob Thornton and uh,
and who else?
Oh,
Bridget Fonda's in it.
This fucking movie is so good.
So well done.
It's about dudes who
find money in the woods,
drug money,
and then they're trying to like,
it's a simple plan.
We're going to hold it
and whack it up together.
We're going to wait some time and then
it just gets more and more complicated
and fucking horrible things
start happening and shit.
Excellent movie.
Well done.
But Billy Bob Thornton gives a performance
in this movie where he ceases to be
Billy Bob Thornton and you're just like,
that character exists.
The man who is in this movie,
there's no connection
to Billy Bob Thornton.
Like it's literally a dude being possessed
of someone else or something like
that.
He changes his look.
Changes is deliver is
every perfect example,
I think to,
to be that good you do.
There has to be a part of you
that's a little bit fucking crazy.
And we know Billy Bob Thornton
is a little bit fucking crazy,
no doubt about Meryl Streep.
She,
you think she's a little bit of,
she just keeps it together.
By then she keeps her composure and
then she just got better composure,
more self aware,
but that the demon inside her beats
just as freely as it does in Billy Bob.
She just knows how to control
it and our social life,
but she can blast it out when she's
pretended to be some other person.
She can just let that fucking demon free.
You know?
Uh,
Billy Bob Thornton is crazy as fuck.
Yes.
I think to a certain extent,
yes and no.
I think it's completely containable.
Yeah.
I,
I've seen Daniel Day Lewis get
interviewed and I think he's,
you know,
he's a brilliant guy who's clearly
like doing it as an artist.
You know,
he's clearly got a good handle on the
whole celebrity thing when the guy like,
he quit movies to be a fucking shoe
cobbler and he said his crazy deep,
interesting Weirdo.
That is one of those stories that like
everybody knows that Daniel Day Lewis.
Yeah.
Abo think it captured
everybody's imagination.
Whether he was serious about it or not.
It may have been his most
brilliant fucking move
because for the next 10 years,
whenever somebody says Daniel Day Lewis,
somewhere in the next
minute they're going to go,
you know,
he was a fucking,
he quit to be a cobbler.
He studied shoe making.
Like it captured people's imagination.
Like why would a guy this
good at the job go off,
quit and make shoes for what?
He came back sooner or later.
But that shoe thing captures
people's imagination.
And you think he probably went
to it because it wasn't acting.
It was the furthest thing from acting.
Cause you're right,
you look at dude,
who gets into a role like he does,
he probably does go to
someplace fucking dark and you,
you know,
a crew,
a bunch of years of doing that,
one after another.
Maybe go on a fucking make shoes in Milan.
Feels good.
Sounds good.
Simple.
Doesn't require much.
Use a different part of your brain.
No darkness and fucking Koblin.
You know,
unless one of those fucking witches
show some of his movies where he does go
dark are the darkest characters
in the history of cinema,
the fucking guns,
gangs and you love it.
Jesus Christ build a butcher.
That's what his name was,
right.
Jesus Christ.
Who's at a fucking scary
performance isn't any accent great.
Yeah,
he'd seems like he really would cut
your fucking head off with a machete.
One of the lucky.
Really.
It's real.
You're feeling it all the way.
The one and the only conversations I
ever had with Martin Scorsese was after a
screening of that movie.
I was coming out of the
theater and I hear somebody go,
Kevin,
and it sounds like Martin
Scorsese were like,
no way.
Martin Scorsese would be fucking saying
Kevin and I turned around and Martin
Scorsese was sang Kevin.
He was talking to me and I was like,
Whoa,
holy shit man.
How are you?
Did you ball tangle?
I very much.
You know what I'm saying?
Like in a way of life.
Like the way he called
me wasn't quite peer,
but it was like he had no
reason to know my name exactly.
And he's like,
what'd you think?
I said,
I fucking loved it man.
Like an I'd stayed through autocrats,
which I said,
Oh my God,
I love that.
You got to tell me how did
he arrive at that accent?
And he goes,
we found cylinders,
old cylinders recorded around what is
18 whatever it turned the centered 19
whatever that period flick was set.
He said,
we found cylinders,
which we just sat there and played
and Daniel took the accent from there,
worked on a little bit and
took the accent from there.
And I was like,
what are the cylinder sound like?
He goes,
surprisingly crystal clear and like you
could literally hear what a person like
what that guy sounded like in that era.
I see an amazing,
I mean it was Danny Lewis is probably
our best representation of it cause I bet
he nailed it.
He must've,
because we've never heard the cylinder.
I've never seen him not
nail something down.
He played a boxer and it's the best
version of an actor playing a boxer ever.
He really looks like a boxer.
Like as he's moving,
he's doing everything correctly.
The way he's holding his hands,
the Lay's responding to being hit the
ways following through with his punches,
with his footwork.
He leaves literally looked like
he could be a professional boxer.
This takes so much energy
and focus to get that good.
Like he didn't just look like an actor.
He wasn't.
They taught how to box like is a perfect
example and I don't mean to diss them
but Marky mark,
Mark Walberg,
whatever.
The fighter and the fight.
It was a great movie.
I love this performance in the movie but
when you watch him boxing it looks like
an actor is boxing.
Okay.
Really?
Cause I thought he was like,
it looks like you can box.
I bet he can box.
I bet he can box but it doesn't look like,
like when you watch
Daniel Day Lewis do it.
Daniel Day Lewis is moving like
a real professional boxer in.
When you watch him,
the Mark Wahlberg thing,
it seems like I'm watching
a movie watching a movie
where there's boxing in it
is there's a,
there's a difference in the reality.
What about Stallone?
Did he convinced?
No,
no,
he didn't look like a box and I never,
I mean he looks like a
guy could kick your ass.
Oh,
they'll get a wrong.
Louis does the does the way a way,
a professional fighter
moves is very specific.
You have to,
unless you're some Roy Jones Jr freak of
nature athlete who can keep your hands
down and do all kinds of
crazy shit because nobody
can touch you because you're
so fast and your timing is so good.
But there's only a few of those guys ever.
And if you look at a classic boxer,
they have very,
you know,
very simple characteristics.
The hands are always up high.
The Chin's tucked,
the shoulders are up.
Nobody does that in a movie and a movie.
Everybody,
their hands are down the throne,
wild punches and flexing their muscles
and it's my turn to hit you and then it's
your turn.
He hit me and it looks very obvious.
Nobody,
I've never get into like
a 32nd 42nd embrace.
None of like where they
have to get split up.
You can't do it realistically unless
you're going to let people hit people and
you don't want to do that because you
only got to get one shot at it and people
aren't going to like it.
No one's going to like a
halfway fight and it's not it.
It's like,
I'm going to let you hit me and
then I'm going to hit you back.
We're going to agree that there's a
certain amount of times we're going to hit
each other.
We're going to hit each
other realistically hard.
You can't do that.
You can't do it.
You can't fake it.
I could do it.
Yeah,
because they can do it realistically,
real easy.
Let me ask you this.
Other than Daniel Day Lewis,
who has convincingly fought in a
movie that earned your respect,
where you're like,
all right,
that looks like it.
Other than Daniel Day Lewis
was that bars too fucking high,
dude.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Washington.
Denzel Washington.
When he played a ruin,
her current started fucking hot.
Can't you give me some of somebody?
It's just like,
nope,
you need a guy like that.
You need a bad mother fucker
who just really commit over.
Like my friend Terry Clay Bond,
uh,
trained him for some of that and he would
go down to the Hollywood boxing gym.
It was on Labrea and uh,
he said that guy would be out there
every fucking morning at seven o'clock.
Blair in his music,
in the parking lot,
fired up,
and he said he would run up the stairs
and he would train like a professional
boxer.
He said he did everything
I asked him to do,
did it exactly the way
I told him to do it.
Skipped rope,
sit ups.
When he's in there every day,
he literally transformed himself
into a professional boxer.
There's a,
there's only a few guys
who can hit that level,
that Daniel Day Lewis,
that Denzel Washington
level of commitment.
And it was only a few
guys who can do that.
So Daniel,
so that was the only two guys that
I've ever seen that looked like real
fighters.
Daniel Day Lewis and Denzel
Washington fighting each other.
Who went Daniel Lewis,
can the fuck add it as a crazy one?
I had,
it's gotta be done.
So he'll get tired.
He'll gas out.
He'll start off strong.
Daniel taking punches for talking shit,
Bro.
Talking about talking shit.
I just have to guess if I looked at the
boxer that Daniel Day Lewis was and I
looked at the box or the,
you know,
Denzel Washington was,
I think Denzel Washington.
He looks like a very good athlete.
Moves very well,
but it looks more like Daniel
Day Lewis is a real boxer.
If we base it on their movie rules,
then uh,
Daniel Day Lewis held out long time
as John proctor and the crucible.
Denzel Washington,
one of the best actors ever,
right?
When you say,
Oh God,
yeah.
And you know what they gave them when?
When they gave him the Oscar for a,
what was it?
You Know Kong?
No,
that was the thing.
They should have given them to them.
Oh,
right,
right.
That performance.
If you ever go watch Malcolm Max footage,
you know,
on Youtube,
but you can now they've got
tons of it and nothing but free.
Fascinating.
You look at that and
you realize like that.
Do you want to talk about a Denzel
Washington and up at six training like a
boxer,
he didn't even have
youtube to pull clips from.
He became Malcolm x.
The mannerisms,
the way he holds his hand,
uh,
as he speaks,
it's in,
it's crazy.
He should've gotten,
I think he got nominate.
He should've won that year.
He didn't.
Then they gave it to him years later for,
to a King Kong and got nothing on me.
The training day,
training day,
which he was really good in it.
That's the thing.
He's like,
I remember when they
first gave him the award,
I hadn't seen the movie.
I was like,
oh,
they're making up for fucking
overlooking Malcolm x.
But then you see his performance in
that movie and what could be a simple
programmer or a simple,
a good guy,
bad guy.
He ticked that role to the next level.
Um,
so it may have been overdue payback
for a fantastic performance.
He didn't get enough credit for,
but I think he earned that 10.
I agree.
A hundred training day.
100% this performance alone.
Yeah.
He,
he,
he legitimately seem like a corrupt cop.
Yeah.
He,
he becomes it.
He's the one of those guys.
It was Russell Crowe guys sick.
You believe sociopathic and like
him giving them the like smoking.
Then he's like,
you're smoking the wet
and like he enjoyed it.
He was a little malicious.
Seem real.
Very real when he was enjoying it.
Yeah.
I mean to,
to put your minds that place
to allow yourself to go there.
You've got to get real close to crazy.
You got to get right next
door neighbors to crazy.
You got to see crazy every morning
when you're getting any cars morning.
Crazy.
What's the crazy issues?
Who's who you worked with?
Like I've seen someone go to that place.
We on RedState we would Michael Parks.
I don't think I've ever said Michael
Parks and Melissa Leo went to weird places
like incredible places where I'm like,
Oh shit,
this is other worldly stuff
like true fucking actors,
man.
True across the Michael
Parks is the preacher.
Yeah.
This and folks,
if you see one movie this year,
see red state,
it's Kevin wants me to this movie.
Now listen,
I had known that Eo thing.
I knew nothing of what this movie was.
I had no idea and I showed up.
I showed up with Aubrey and we had not
a fucking clue in the world as to what
this movie is about.
I assumed it was a comedy and
I heard some whisper online.
I heard it was a horror
film question mark.
That's all I saw.
So I go in with an awesome blank
slate and it halfway into the movie,
I'm like,
what the fuck is going on?
it may be 35 45 minutes in.
I was like,
this is the craziest fucking,
this is Kevin Smith's movie.
It's seats.
You don't even,
it's like you have to throw out everything
you think of as a Kevin Smith movie.
Kevin Smith movies are always fun.
Comedies,
you know,
in this movie just gets so fucking
crazy so quick and just keeps and goes.
And you know,
I really,
I appreciate so much about that movie,
but what I really,
well,
the one thing that's staggering right
off the bat was that guy who played the
preacher,
Michael Parks of Mosley.
If that guy doesn't get
nominated for the academy award,
he loves so much attention,
uh,
fuck awards,
right?
Fuck,
fuck theW who cares?
You know,
it's,
I mean,
to a seven year old man or this business
turned its back on a long time ago and
clearly has better chops and most of
his peers who went on to other things,
it means something.
That award,
it may not mean shit to me,
like me getting awards,
but him,
that award means something and it's still,
he comes from an era where it
does mean it does mean so well.
I wish we could substitute that with the,
the greater opinion of,
you know,
whatever people,
nice people all across the country
and people discerning individuals.
If you watch this movie and don't think
this guy's a fucking super genius,
all that Shit that I said
about Daniel Day Lewis,
the exact same shit I'm
saying about this guy,
one of those right there,
he was playing this fucking preacher and
he had this one long non cut monologue.
I mean the camera is on him for a long
fucking time and it's all one run and
it's brilliant.
It's brilliant.
He sucks you in to the point
where you're shitting your,
you know,
this is going to,
something terrible is going to happen.
You don't know when you
don't know what and it keeps,
he just holds you there with this
conviction in this character and this
character is belief that is fucking scary.
It's fucking scary.
There's,
you know,
there's imminent death.
Yeah.
Like it's set up right there,
but his performance is so riveting.
He's so,
so fucking good at the
craft that you'll put,
cause the movie's moving along
at a nice clip right there.
We put the movie on pause and be like,
Ladies and gentlemen,
Michael Parks,
and it does a fucking
essentially a guitar Solo,
the Most Amazing Guitar
Solo you've ever heard.
And rather than be like,
move on,
fucking get to the murders
that we knew were coming.
People that kicked back and go like,
oh my God,
that's so beautiful.
And he finishes his solo
and the movie begins again.
It's,
it's pretty weird.
It's pretty astounding.
Guitar Solo.
What kind of music you or you saw it.
It's him.
It's his voice.
I'm talking about a metaphorical,
oh Jesus Christ and I was so high.
More stone than me.
I must be possible cause you keep going.
You keep going and
dragging me in with you.
I'm telling you,
I've been around at all.
Vege wow.
I'm an idiot.
This ain't even happening.
We're in this meditation tech.
You're in the meditation tank and
we're just having this conversation.
How did that character come about?
Oh yeah,
for sure.
I'll let you know how the
character coming back at that guy,
Fred Phelps.
What?
How much of this church
guy and basically that that dude created
that character for me that create the
movie for you a little bit.
I mean it was kind of a
two or three pronged thing.
Like number one,
I saw parks in from dusk till dawn,
which was a Quinton's movie with Robert
Rodriguez and he's in the opening 10
minutes.
He's astounding.
Like the,
the this I,
I love acting.
I love actors,
love people,
actresses,
people that could take the words off page,
Meghan Sing.
But you know,
there's only so many ways
to skin a cat and fucking,
even the best of him,
pretty much like concede
the strings and whatnot.
You know how acting works.
Every once in a while you meet one of
these performers or see of her former,
you're lucky you get to meet him.
It takes it off the fucking
grid off the charts.
This guy does this and
the opening of this movie,
which from dusk till
dawn is a fun vampire,
fucking Romp Romp.
Rather,
this guy comes in and drops a
performance that could have won.
It showed him in a fair just world would
have won a supporting Oscar nomination.
Like you know,
Judi Dench gets one for Shakespeare
in love and she's in the movie.
What?
Seven or nine minutes?
Parks in from dusk till dawn,
roughly the same time and
gives a performance that's
as electric as believable
as off the charts.
Wonderful.
But you know,
it's a genre film so he don't
get the attention and stuff.
This guy fell in love with him.
I'm watching a from dusk till dawn,
1995 to lendlease,
lendlease sunset five uh,
Bob Weinstein's.
Thank you Manny [inaudible] and VIP.
It's movie has a Gaf.
Fuck Alan.
I see the vampire movie and I went to go
see this vampire movie made by Quentin
Tarantino and Robert Rodriguez.
But what I left there was with,
I have to work with that man.
I don't know who that fucking man is.
That sheriff guy in the
first 10 minutes who?
Spoilers,
spoilers,
movies.
Fucking 16 years old,
but just in case he gets killed,
the first fucking 10 minutes whole movie.
I'm like,
no.
That dude was the fucking truth.
The absolute truth.
I walk out of that theater,
I go,
I got to work with that guy to sit at
the fucking feet of a Yoda like that.
And like for a month on a set,
you man imagining my mouth fucking
information you can glean steel fucking
benefit from.
He's pure,
pure genius enacting form a clear
genius when you're watching him.
It's so spectacular and riveting.
So good.
I told them there were
days on set like I did.
We didn't do many takes at
all because we were just,
you know,
we didn't have a lot of money and
she was low budget movie and when the
performances are that
good man got John Gum,
I'm Melissa Leo,
you've got parks,
the crushing it take one and shit.
So you know,
I'll leave it up to them and they're like,
I'm good if you're good.
I'm like,
I know I got,
I don't direct the movie as much as I
sit there and edit it in my head on set.
And because you don't direct Michael
Parkinson when willing to do go up to him
and be like,
here's how I do it based on my experience.
Plants Silent Bob over the years.
Did he ad libbed any of that?
Oh yeah.
He got in there and definitely seemed
like he could probably just start talking
in that guy.
Uh,
he sees so in tune with
that fucking character man.
Yeah,
he was,
well,
he,
he had that script for what,
two,
three months ahead of time by the
time he came to the set and I have no,
I'm not the author of that performance.
I got authored his own performance
hands down there across the boards.
You don't direct the movie like Red State.
You just let it happen.
But all they should keep it on the tracks.
This dude's like his,
uh,
he would,
he had the script for a while
when he came to the set.
He is like,
can I,
can I have the space?
Can you show them into space?
And we brought them to
the chapel and whatnot.
They were still putting the
finishing touches on it,
but he kind of did a a laid out like
the way you would lay out a dance.
He essentially kind of didn't say the
dialogue out loud but he would just sit
there and you'd watch them kind of moving
his arms and stuff and it looked like
he was slowly waltzing by himself and
they'd stop somewhere and ask somebody,
put a mark here,
blah blah blah.
I'll put a mark here.
Then he put it all together.
I got to see what he was doing the next
morning he had choreograph this fucking
thing.
Like he could do it from top to bottom.
Like he could do the entire scene,
which was I think in the script.
12 pages,
12 pages of dialogue or
something ridiculous like
that and he could fucking do
it from beginning to end.
And you watch him hit his marks.
He knew exactly where
he wanted to ban stuff.
So much so that like I had done a draft
right before shooting and I was like,
hey man,
this is the new version of the sermon.
And he fucking bristled.
Cause he was like,
no,
no.
I mean that's other stuff's great.
What do you need this for?
Blah Blah.
And what I realized was
because he was dialed in,
like he knew what was going to
happen when you hit that stage.
He knew where to be so that he could
just let his art come out of his mouth.
But he was still framing the movie for us,
still commanding the stage.
It's a movie,
let's keep things moving.
He wasn't content to just stand
there and deliver dialogue,
which he could have and he still
would have fucking captivated you.
Instead he choreographed his movement.
Um,
it,
it was fantastic.
He was a dude that just
gave beyond given you,
you know,
I,
I wrote it with him in mind going,
I know what it's gonna sound like cause
I'm a big fan of the students' work now.
And even getting to the set,
he would still deliver over
what I heard in my head.
Like,
oh,
like I remember,
I'll never forget what a month,
month before we start shooting,
where in my kitchen's May John Gordon
is Bruce through the movie and um,
and parks and we're just talking about
when we're going to go and it takes a
while to get money together.
And so we're leaving the kitchen and
that we're talking about something in the
script and he stops and he goes,
he drew delivers one of the lines
and he delivers it so flawlessly.
And it was the first time I heard
parks do what would be avian Cooper.
And so I was like,
oh my God,
parks.
My heart skipped a beat and shit.
He left and I turned to John Gordon.
I was like,
dude,
he's going to win an award.
I don't know what it is,
but like there's no way
people don't cite him.
It was like it for that one line,
he slipped into a,
and Cooper,
you could hear it.
You can the Gravitas of the
life that Michael Parks has led,
informing like every,
every job he did or didn't get an
entire life brought to bear on this,
he gave him,
he gave a monster soul.
Like you look at that
character on the page,
very two dimensional,
easy to hey Michael,
put a sole on them where you know,
you still hate them,
but you're like,
oh there's this somebody under there.
You know,
he's not just like a
two dimensional cartoon.
You could easily write off.
He brought something to it and I wanted
him to do two dimensional cartoon.
Like I was just like,
I'm gonna put you in track suits.
Cause that's what Fred
Phelps wears and you know,
you could talk like him.
He goes,
I don't want to do that.
If you want me to do
Fred Phelps impression,
get somebody else who's gone,
man,
it's fucking boring.
He's like,
I came to act.
I was like right on.
And he did charismatic instead.
Wow.
He's a dude,
man.
He don't fuck around.
This is a duty as a straight shooter,
you seven years old,
he's not pulling punches.
He's going to tell you exactly
are you fucking feels and he,
what is it that have Bisbee
a little intimidating though
when you have that kind
of a conversation with him.
You wanted him to do that though,
right?
Yeah.
I wanted him to do all this
because of him and like he'll give,
you know,
like I'm a grown up so
I can take good ideas,
leave stuff behind.
He gave me the wonderful
idea of seen the movie.
Like it ends with somebody going shut
the fuck up from off camera without
spoilers,
spoilers.
Um,
that came from parks.
It wasn't in the script,
it was just,
you know,
just ended where it
kinda ended without that.
And parks was like,
how about instead you go off of
me and I'm trying to be vague.
So it was not to spoil it,
but I hope you remember
what I'm talking about.
I do totally go off of me singing and
then you go down to another cell and there
you are,
you know,
and,
and you see,
given away way too much.
Your movie right now it's a little bit,
but again,
I said spoilers,
but I tune out folks.
Yeah.
But anyway,
he goes to you say blah blah blah.
He said that line.
And I was just like,
um,
I said parks I would love to but I think
it'd be weird in this moment I saw,
I liked the idea that line.
I said,
but cutting to me in the movie,
I'm not in the movie.
And I think people would take
people out of the movie and he goes,
why?
And I was gone because people would
recognize me and he goes from what?
And I realize like,
oh my gosh guys,
like not,
he has no clue that like I've had this
whole other career as far as he knows
that it's red state and red.
So he only knows I made some movies,
has no idea what they are,
didn't know I was in them or anything.
That was so sweet.
It was going in pure,
you know what I'm saying?
Like this dude went in all about the
craft and he drops science on that
performance.
And he would sit there from
time to time like and be like,
can I grab one more take?
And I'd be like,
parks,
you can have as many takes as you want.
We're literally all here because of you.
Because I saw that performance
and from dusk till dawn.
So it was kind of like the whole
movie was kind of a parks celebration.
You know,
people that didn't know him fell in love
with them as we made the movie because
the dude just every day you
were awed by something he did.
But you were sitting there going,
oh my God.
Like do you remember when he
started singing in the movie?
At one point we had the whole chapel,
you know,
everyone in the chapel singing and,
and I said,
uh,
for some other part of the movie,
he said,
Hey man,
uh,
while this thing's going
on over here on camera,
I'm going to push in on you.
You want to sing one of
those Gospel hymnals.
Cause he picked the other
one old rugged cross.
I said,
you got another one you want to go with?
And he's like,
yeah man,
the AUC can sink farther along.
You want that?
And I was like,
yeah,
whatever shirt.
Totally.
And we shoot them,
we're pushing in on him
and he sings farther along.
And it's Kinda is,
it is in the movie.
He's got this beautiful soulful voice.
The men had made records.
So,
um,
oh,
it's,
it sweeps me off my feet
and it's a church song,
but I'm still weighing into it.
Next day I come into work,
everyone on set periodically here and go
my father alone and they're all singing
it and I'm like,
it's good.
I said,
right?
Like,
it's catchy to like,
yeah,
for Jesus Song is pretty catchy and stuff.
So he brought that to
it to the elements of,
of singing charisma,
charisma.
And that's what he went for.
He said he wanted to
play it as a charismatic,
he had this whole backstory for like,
you know,
his not only even Cooper's father,
but his grandfather,
he was like,
oh,
he's very close with his grandfather,
wrote a backstory.
He's himself to create for the care.
Yeah,
he told me he's just like,
look,
he was tight with his grandfather and
his grandfather was still fire and
brimstone,
who's charismatic,
but he was still strict but
it's grandfather is still
also had a sense of humor
for the kid.
So his grandfather would
be the one in the kitchen,
you know,
pulling like a train whistle down with
had one fist and lifting a leg and fart
and with the other.
So we were still kind of human so he
loved his grandfather had Cooper even
though we premium preached the
holy word and he loved them for it.
His father also preached the holy word,
this,
this killed me cause parks
going on all eloquently.
It goes,
his father also preached the holy word,
but he probably touched his dick.
So we don't talk about his father ever.
I was like,
that's astounding dude.
That's amazing.
You just bizarre.
But he gave it thought,
he gave thought into
buying the outfit duty,
went out and picked out to the
the wardrobe with Beth costume.
A wardrobe person picked every piece.
She was us like never
really done that before.
Ghana,
you know,
gone out with girls who are
looking for a specific sizes,
but he right down to the
underwear and the socks.
The dude had to be involved in picking
the choices that what aid he fell
represented.
Yeah.
And he put the outfit together.
I remember the first time she showed
me a picture of him in the office,
Beth Beth up past Beth Beth pock.
Anyway,
regardless,
best shows me pictures of uh,
a bin and um,
and in his outfit,
Michael Parks and I'm going,
oh man,
that ain't it at all.
I was looking for a track suit,
like this dude wearing Khakis
and button down shirt and a tie.
It looks like a school teacher.
And I had,
you know,
had written,
I'd read state in my
brain for like five years,
you know,
wrote a five years ago.
And I'd always had very specific
idea of what he looked like,
which was stolen from
the look of Fred Phelps.
And I remember going like,
I dunno man,
like,
how do I adjust this?
I don't want him to wear this.
And she,
she was like,
you might want to go with it.
He's dialed into the costume and it was
such a good choice because the clothes
made the man like,
I don't even know how else to say.
I did sound,
it sounds Corny,
but the,
the outfit made him just allowed
to do what he had to do up there.
He felt like if you see
him early in the movie,
at one point he's at the protests holding
the cup of coffee outside is wearing
just a jacket,
a windbreaker and a tee shirt or some,
but whenever he spoke the holy word,
he would put on what,
you know,
his Sunday best essentially
and this was his Sunday best,
like the button down shirt with a
tie and he believed in presenting,
particularly if you're going to go
up there and preach the holy word,
you should look respectable and bullet
all this philosophy behind just the
outfit and the whole time I feared it
until we want in front of cameras and I
was like,
this looks beautiful.
Like the outfit is perfect and in some
weird way because it gives him this just
air of respectability and that makes the
shit coming out of his mouth that much
more heinous.
I realize I'm still standing.
So he was uh,
yeah,
he's uh,
that guy's a unique talent.
It's hard to believe that
it's taken them this long for,
um,
Mo,
it's taken me this long
to find out who he is.
You know,
like why doesn't America,
Quentin and Robert Quentin Tarantino
particularly made that guy charming,
quick story.
I love the story because shows you that
we're all like fucking kids in this
business.
We go see the movie acquaintance
guys own fucking movie theaters.
House looks like a fucking
real movie theater,
movie seats,
fucking popcorn shit.
And he's got these awesome sculptures
from his movies all around by this artist
named cleat shields.
Great own personal movement there.
Sits about 50 or 60 or something
like that and maybe a little less.
So we go watch red state.
There's me,
Gwen and parks,
Michael Parks.
And he liked it.
He liked it.
See they really loved,
I don't want to oversell it,
but he dug the movies so much.
He watched it without us
when he wasn't supposed to.
Like he got the print two days early.
We're supposed to watch it with them the
day that we joined him and he was like,
I'm gonna be honest with you.
I watched her ready twice.
Fucking love it.
You know,
I was like,
oh the,
you don't have to apologize but
us fucking awesome and shit.
So he watched it with us again.
Then afterwards he goes,
come in the house and you know,
cause the theaters separate from the
house and he brings us in the house and
this fucking charmed me.
I will never forget this.
He goes,
I got to show you my tape.
I got to show you my Michael Parks tape.
And he goes into,
you know,
he's got a big entertainment centers,
DVDs everywhere and stuff
hightech everywhere.
But he also still has VHS.
Dude lays hands on a fucking VHS tape
almost as if I thought I hit the fucking
flux capacitor cause I haven't seen one
in a while and they're scribble on the
fucking side and marker.
Because remember we used to ride on the
side of our video tapes when we made our
own tapes.
Um,
Beth,
the best of Michael Parks and Quentin
throws this tape in and what it is,
is he such a fan of this guy's work,
he loves him.
Gone back to then came Bronson.
He loves this dude's work so much.
Anytime this dude's going to turn
up on TV or it gets a video of him,
he v he records from tape to tape or
from TV to tape the segments of his
performance,
everything that Michael Parks and
particularly the highlights and shit.
So what you have is a collection of
like some of the cheesiest exploitation,
straight to TV movies or straight,
you know,
Blake about of high school volleyball
team or college volleyball team and stuff
like that.
Murder mysteries and whatnot,
like real programmers.
And as he's shown you the clips,
even though it's
programmers all around him,
Michael Parks is still in each one of
these scenes that Quentin is pulled off
and put onto this VHS dropping science
performance science where you're just
like,
this is crazy.
Like this dude's doing Shakespeare
in the middle of Shit and yeah,
not to put off,
you know,
anybody who made those movies
down or off or whatever,
but clearly like everyone
else has kind of like,
you know,
here we are collecting a check and that
is about the best furthest we can go.
And this dude is like crushing it,
crushing it.
Like what movies?
A lot of TV,
I don't even know them do Darl TV movies
from like the sixties and seventies is
a little bit into the 80s and
that's what Quentin had collected.
He would like this,
he's got an encyclopedic knowledge of,
of cinema and even bad trash cinema.
There is no such trash,
such thing as trashed cinema to this guy.
He watched that movie and he found gold
like diamonds in the midst of Shit that
was just maybe simple or
fucking program and material.
And he collected them for years on a
fucking VHS tape long before he ever knew
he would be a filmmaker,
long before he ever knew
he'd meet Michael Parks,
let alone become a film maker,
make movies with Michael Parks and them
direct Michael Parks and inspire me to
make a fucking movie where I
put Michael Parks in it like he,
that's what he said to me.
It's like,
oh my God,
he's gone as a Michael Parks Fan,
I love this.
This is an,
Oh,
this is the ultimate Michael Parks movie.
I was like,
right,
right.
So for me it was,
that was,
I loved that the tape dude,
he still had it.
If he had just told us the
story of ice to this tape,
man,
when I had the best,
that would have been cool enough,
dude.
But he produced it and we all watched
it together and I sat in a chair off to
the side and him and park sat
on a couch and it was there.
I would've rolled the tier if it wouldn't
have embarrassed him both or made them
be able to get out.
Um,
but there they were like the man whose,
whose work that this kid,
filmmaker loved so much.
Think about the shit you made
mix tapes of when you were a kid.
He made him this guy's performance and
there he is watching that very same tape
with the guy on the tape,
the WHO,
you know,
the actor he loves.
Oh,
it was touching.
That's inspiring.
But it's also inspiring that
this guy's like Tarantino out.
They're real enthusiasts,
you know,
due to get really fucking super excited
about some shit and that's like you
with,
with fucking MMA or whatever.
Fuck.
Like the shit that you're into your
super into you get geeky about.
Yeah.
He does Kiki fucking movies.
And that passion will translate
to an audience for everything.
When,
uh,
whenever it is that you're doing,
man,
I never want to see a fucking,
you was UFC,
UFC fight,
but you,
when you talked about it in the shower
was just like when you came on our show,
I was like,
Oh,
you know,
I would go see this now.
Like you,
when you talk about it with the passion,
enthusiasm you do translates to somebody
who was never sold before and I wasn't
even on the fence really.
But then when I watch you talk about,
I'm like,
this motherfucker's smart.
Like he's one of the smartest dudes I
ever met that everyone was running the
organizations.
Yeah,
intelligent.
It's,
it's,
it's a totally different
thing than what people expect.
Right?
Hear the term cage fighting.
You think,
well,
there's going to be a bunch of,
you know,
barbaric assholes and you know,
and,
and mean people beaten up.
Other mean people.
That's not what it is at all.
I mean,
what it is,
is people that are trying to attempt to
do the most difficult thing in all of
sport.
Put your body and your health at risk to
go after another person's body and shut
it down and taken out.
It's the craziest game of all time.
But it's the oldest game of all time.
Male dominance over other men.
And look,
we have a society where
obviously that's illegal.
You can't,
you can't beat people up.
You can't.
It's good.
We want everything to be civilized,
we want,
but in the midst of evolution,
when we find ourselves in this,
this stage along the way from changing
from a a wild animal to a conscious
being,
we still got a lot of chimpanzee DNA that
needs to be satisfied and there's one
or two ways to do it.
Either you can suppress it,
you can pretend it doesn't exist,
or you can give it something like porn
or violence on television and movies and
in,
in sports.
You could give it something
to live vicariously through.
I like porn.
Yes.
If,
cause,
if you don't have these other ways
to live vicariously through it,
there's only one other way around it.
You have to go find whatever
it is you're looking for,
whether it's fine violence or find sex.
But if you can get violence
and sex and a television form,
you can eliminate it from real life.
The Japanese have believed this forever.
The Japanese believe that you know,
you're much more likely to commit a
heinous sexual crimes if it's difficult to
get laid.
You know,
there's so freaky over there.
You can buy used women's
panties and dispensers.
It's ridiculous.
You put some cash,
you buy underwear.
Porn is,
there's no pubic hair.
It's only nipples.
And even those are kind of
very strange shaking out.
But their animation and their comic books.
Yeah.
Fucking like intense.
A lot of bondage.
Giant Cox two,
yeah.
Giant vein later.
Not Allowed to see hair,
pubic hair.
So bizarre.
Yeah,
they have a,
it's an,
it's got to be weird when an entire
country looks so similar physically.
I mean,
obviously you can tell the difference
between one Japanese guy to another.
I know a lot of Japanese people,
but essentially the vast majority of the
people that live in Japan have this one
look dark hair.
You know,
the,
the Japanese look,
I mean,
they are a clear race,
you know,
it's gotta be so strange to be a
part of such a specific ethnicity.
Like I'm a Mutt.
You look like you're probably a month.
You're a mud.
You know,
we're a combinations.
I'm a little bit of Irish,
a little bit of Italian,
but you know,
I'm just a white guy,
you know,
to most people.
But when you,
you know,
Japanese people like Dan
is a very clear race,
has got to be very strange to be a part
of like a real powerful dominant like,
you know what I'm saying?
Like,
it's like,
like you look at like,
uh,
like,
like it's some Italians,
you can see this and you know,
you,
you look at them and go,
oh clearly that guys some
sort of an Italian guy,
you know?
Or if not he's Armenian
or something like that,
you know,
that the sort of dark look.
But it could be a bunch of different
things Japanese guys look like Japanese
guys,
you know,
if you understand what like the
w with Asian people look like,
you know,
Koreans have a different look to them.
But it's,
it must be interesting to
be a part of like one of,
I mean,
how many millions of
Japanese people are there,
you know,
and to have such a similar look with
all these different people that like you
that you could be recognized immediately
somewhere else in the country.
You know,
I think it'd be awesome to have a culture,
like they have a culture.
Oh if you feel like we,
I mean we have pop culture,
which thank God cause
that's why I have a job,
but they have a culture that goes back
eons and we don't really didn't add them
in.
And as,
as White Mutts,
we don't really have a
culture that goes back eons.
What always impressed me about the
Japanese is the culture of discipline.
They've had this culture of,
of discipline and of martial arts.
You know,
the discipline of,
of,
of war and strategy like way before any
of the European countries ever figured
out what the fuck was going on.
Right.
You know,
the,
this Shogun,
this tattoo that I have on my arm is
Miyamoto Musashi battling a tiger.
This is a,
this famous Samurai guy.
And um,
he wrote this book called
the Book of five rings.
Some amazing book man,
where you got to get into this
guy's head that he's living,
I believe it was the 15th century.
So I think it was like the 14 hundreds.
I'm,
I might be wrong with what he,
whenever he was writing this book,
basically he was a Ronin so
he would travel the earth.
He had no,
uh,
no master.
He had no emperor.
So he was traveling the earth basically
having fucking sword fights with people.
He had like 60 duals one-on-one duels
with other men and killed them and hand to
hand one on one combat.
I mean,
it's a crazy thought and thinking
about killing people with swords.
This guy did until like
60 different guys swords.
And in,
in some situations he,
he thought swords are too easy.
So he would use,
he would let them use a sword and he
would use a stick and he was fucking,
it was a fascinating character,
but his,
his whole life was based on unbalance.
It was about art,
it was about philosophy,
it was about,
it was about seeking the correct way.
And for him,
the way of the sword was simply
the way to be successful.
The most successful movements in any
given situation as far as what combat is.
But he acquainted this
combat to artistic integrity,
the ability to create things freely,
the ability to draw and paint,
the ability to write poetry and and,
and to elegantly
express your feelings.
To him,
it was all connected.
It was all one piece of excellence and
that is like a guide to live your life
by.
And he had this,
this,
this statement that I read when I
was a kid and I always stuck with me.
Once you understand the way broadly,
you can see it in all things.
And the idea,
the idea being that once you find
out how to tap into anything,
it's like find out how to
be a great movie director.
Find out how to be a,
a great guy draws animation,
a fucking singer.
Would a chess player and say it again,
say you're fine.
The,
once you understand the way broadly,
you can see it in all things.
This is a translation from Japanese,
so it's not probably not totally accurate,
but what,
what,
that's what he meant is
that you find greatness.
You find greatness as a carpenter,
you find greatness as a Samurai.
Does that same thing when you just tap
into the zone where you're just really
tuning into whatever the fuck you're
doing and then you let creativity sort of
spread it out for you.
Comes better with age too,
doesn't it?
But it's just like it
comes with awareness.
I think blue awareness and
not even just with age.
I think the age is just experience and
that's awareness or eventually a quick
learners.
I don't think it's
necessarily just an age.
There's a lot of people that
they get older and they,
they put that box closer
and closer to their head.
You know,
they want to see less
and less of the world.
It's,
it's all your,
you're seeking as well.
You're not trapped in some
sort of a box every day,
so as you get older,
of course you're,
you're going to get
more tuned into things.
You're constantly still
asking the questions.
You're not trapped in a slave box.
I used to be a destination guy.
I talked about it with Mosher
on spot cost quite a bit.
Back in the day I was destination.
He was very journey oriented.
For him.
It was all about like,
hey man,
everything's a journey and you know,
it's like the journey is the
fucking fun and Blah Blah Blah.
And I was like,
no destination,
get there.
I just want to get to where we're
supposed to be in the last few years.
I flipped and now I am kind of like the
journey is more important to me and know
why that is.
Why cause you're rich as fuck.
Oh we did that too.
But it's also you're successful.
You don't have to worry about it anymore.
Yeah,
you're fucking Kevin Smith.
He got 2 million friends on
follow followers on Twitter.
You can talk to them whenever you want to.
They want to come and see your movies.
You're in this weird zone where you
don't have to give a fuck anymore.
Yeah.
You know what it is.
And I love the expression and I've it,
but they said,
uh,
they said he doesn't,
Kevin doesn't have to work for anyone
anymore cause he works for the audience.
And I was like,
Oh God,
that's perfect.
It's true.
That's it.
If you could get to that place
where it's not about like,
fuck everyone,
none of it.
You don't rely on anybody for anything.
It's all coming from within you,
your camp or something like that.
Not like there's no help.
Of course you get help within your world,
but do you know how comforting is it is
to know that I don't have to do prep.